Patrick first of all congratulations
thank you difficult tournament up to
this point for you but you're just
simply not giving up and finally it paid
off for you tell us about your initial
feelings after this Victory well it
feels really nice of course I mean you
know it's much better than being a
punching bag and
um being on the other side of the
punching is better and um I feel like it
was a pretty good game I mean I need to
check it of course with the engine but
um you know I think the position out of
the opening was pretty good for me and I
it didn't I didn't feel like I ever lost
the thread no no and I really like this
moment when he took on E3 and you could
have taken with the Knight and well you
have a normal position oh this is still
yeah this is still Theory the theory
here is very interesting like this
position is known but it's not very well
worked out so it's the allappin is like
that it's really really kind of
fascinating to me it's very complicated
it's like you've entered some alternate
universe because not a lot of people
play right no although I've noticed that
um uh uh some like NEPA minichi has been
playing at some and and um no I people
are starting to play it but um I mean
there's lots and lots of games with it
and there's lots of theory but it hasn't
somehow been fully worked out and so a
very strong player like Igor
um I didn't know how well prepared he
would be I knew he if I played against
this Knight or if he'd be very well
prepared right so I figured this was
probably a better idea I knew that he
played something like these systems in
the games I found on him so I figured
some probably something I had no idea
how well prepared he'd be but I think it
goes to show someone as strong as Igor
as well prepared as he generally is
didn't seem to really know how to play
the opening
um which gives you an idea sort of how
like tricky this can be yeah absolutely
no and uh it does seem like you already
have some sort of an advantage and I
have to say this long Castle Queen E4
very forceful moves very concrete moves
well what's really interesting about
this position is there's two ideas and
you really have to work both of them
simultaneously so one is of course the
attack against the king but the other is
there are a lot of end games that are
very good right and so this is actually
like the the secret to this position
somehow is like you have to be willing
to take the end game and you have to use
that perhaps something like this yeah
yeah I mean all oftentimes whenever you
can trade the queens in a pretty good
like oftentimes this night versus like
the light Square Bishop is really bad
yeah the C6 Pawn is really bad you've
got the D file so long as you sort of
hold control it should be generally
pretty good and so of course Queen E4
pokes G6 right so now there's this big
weakness and now Queen F4 and now
maybe this was not the best move I don't
know right now but I like it but uh well
the computer knows better than all but
maybe Queen A4 by the way it's the best
one oh okay well that's the best but but
now like he has a very difficult choice
right he can go into the end game but
that's a really painful end game to play
yeah or he can move the queen away but
now he's created this big weakness with
G6 so now the attacker is always going
to be much stronger yeah yeah and uh
well how is Bishop C2 is that a good
move yes yes yes yes no Bishop C2 is
fine
best move in the position oh that's good
yeah opening up the D file may be
hinting at 96 very nice oh so it thought
before we thought that's interesting yes
hard move to play I I yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting I wondered about
before I couldn't bring myself to do it
and H4 just seems so natural and if you
go Queen G5 you have to understand that
this end game is just like really really
bad for you yeah yeah that's interesting
oh wow but the H4 I mean kind of plays
itself almost right well you know
yeah so E5 was a mistake right yes yeah
I mean it's so difficult to play this
position with black right it's so so
difficult because
the best moves still leave you with a
very bad position yeah and it's it's
like it's very natural to try to get
active but the thing is actually my
night is very strong well I mean of
course taking on D6 has to be correct
right like to give this exchange I mean
his dark squares are terrible nothing
else you're kind of forced to play the
best moves yeah exactly and then the
night there's but that night was really
a hero right it went Knight A3 C4 E5 C6
I thought that was very fun no no indeed
tell us a bit about your routine because
I've been seeing you quite a few times
at the gym you're working out tell us
about your routine I'm 55 years old I
wouldn't call it working out I I would
call it trying to just stay healthy and
be active but yeah I like to go to the
gym in the morning I try to stay fit
um it's very good for tournaments very
good just sort of to wake yourself up
and you know and then I just try to
prepare I mean
um I like I like to think of myself a
little bit like Rip Van Winkle I mean
I've been asleep for 20 years and I've
come back and um A lot's changed and I'm
trying really really hard to catch up
um and somehow like sometimes I I have
like opening knowledge like in my
computer but it's not actually in my
brain yeah so I'm trying as hard as
possible to like put it in my brain
um do you do any coaching on the side do
you help some of the Juniors at all or I
haven't although it's something that I
think would be nice to do I don't teach
professionally
um but um I really don't do anything in
chess professionally but um but you know
I I mean it would be nice to be a mentor
but quite frankly I'm looking at the
Juniors here and I don't think they need
my help they're so good they're really
good really good
um some of oh my gosh they're so by the
way what on Earth was that game that
finished really quickly we saw you
looking at what was going on what was
that is that you're saying preparation
no some insane preparation from Jason
Liang yeah was that new like 35 moves of
theory abhimanyu came with a novelty
that but he was ready for the novelty 35
moves deep basically holy
maybe they'll Mentor me that would be
nice
congratulations thank you thank you guys
any questions absolutely yeah Patrick
congratulations you know thank you very
nice fighting game I'm curious you know
a few days back you had this game with
uh Alex shabalov where you where you
sacrificed the piece and then it didn't
work out today you sacrificed again this
time of an exchange how did that feel
did you think about that previous game
or did it not what's your mind yeah that
game was painful you know
um it's interesting one thing I've
noticed as I've come back is part of
what I need to do is get it back into
the Rhythm right Max and I were having
dinner the other night he was talking
about how for him he had to get back
into the Rhythm and part of it is using
your time but part of it I think is
um managing the emotions and the energy
of the game and there's an old
expression maybe you've heard it when
you see a good a move sit on your hands
right and there might be a better one
and so this game against Alex well
Bishop A6 was the right idea but it was
it was the wrong move the right move in
the position is Queen E3
and then when Black Goes King H7 then
Bishop takes six Bishop takes six G5 and
in that position all three results were
possible right and what happened in that
game is I played the opening poorly Alex
just outplayed me but I still met I
still had an okay I think he missed like
one shot to have a really big advantage
and then I still had a normal position
but I felt under a lot of pressure and
when he castled I thought oh my gosh
this is my chance but I didn't think
right this is an incredibly important
moment in the game and I should have
just thought more carefully and I didn't
and afterwards I realized like part of
what I need to sort of get back into and
manage it's again it's not just the
opening preparation it's also just the
rhythm and and and and the emotions so
to answer your question this time
sacrificing The Exchange well of course
it's much easier when you have a good
position to start with and
um I I think I did a much better job of
just sort of like thinking carefully you
know Bishop C2 like I had a long thing
you know queen queen E4 Queen F4 like
these moments I was I took I think the
right amount of time and was able to
figure out good moves and for Bishop D6
I didn't see it all the way out to the
end but I saw Rook takes D6 Queen takes
and H5 and I analyzed that enough and I
just figured I mean this has to be
really good so so it felt very different
and I think I think I did a better job
but of course I was helped by the fact
that I got a good position out of the
opening our congratulations uh once
again as we have two results in